how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how do I
get in but let me but I have to comment
on this on this neoliberalism failure
not the time in neoliberal is because I
think they're way too moderate but I
mean to look around the world today and
see darkness is to have shades to be
wearing shades I travel all over the
world I've spoken in 60 different
countries when I go around the world
when I go to Eastern Europe or I go to
Asia or I go to China or you go to
Vietnam or you go to any of these
countries what you're seeing is that the
creation of markets the ability to have
free markets even in limited
circumstances brings out human potential
people are so hungry to be free as
individuals so hungry to be left alone
from the state dictating every single
aspect of their lives and as a
consequence a billion people over a
billion people have come out of extreme
poverty over the last thirty years and
you can ignore that you could pretend it
didn't happen
but globalization has brought more
wealth to the world has helped poverty
the poor more than any other theoretical
abstract system in human history over a
billion people over the last thirty
years have come out of extreme poverty
the middle there's a middle class today
in India and in in in China that did not
exist 30 years ago 30 years ago 30
percent of the planet lived on under $2
a day today the numbers under 9 percent
now that should be something we should
be celebrating and asking the question
how did this happen this is indeed a
beautiful thing none of it happened
because of foreign aid none of it
happened because of the exploitation of
Marxist ideology they already had that
it's indeed the rejection of that
Marxist ideology it's the rejection of
central planning it's the rejection of
the idea of the proletarian that is
brought this around it's it's the fact
that don't try paying
as evil of nough bastard that he was was
willing to say look it worked in Hong
Kong maybe we should try this in the
area around Hong Kong and see what
happens we'll just leave them alone and
when you leave people along when you
leave people free then they create
things that exceed our imagination
because you are liberating the human
potential and that is true if you if you
go back to hundred fifty years ago 95
percent of humanity lived in $2 a day or
less imagine your own lives on $2 a day
or less we want we people people tell me
you know we have a lot of anxiety in
life today think about living where
you're growing your own food and half
your children are dying before age 10
that is the world before capitalism
before free market capitalism is the
greatest Liberator and human history of
the poor of ever the 95 percent who used
to be in a junk poverty it is the
greatest it is the greatest system we
have ever come across and the antagonism
towards it I find mystifying because
again human life has never ever ever
been better than it is right now and
it's it could be a lot better that will
agree on because I don't think what
capitalists enough we don't take our
capitalism seriously enough and there's
a trick in your question right because
you have equated fairness with equality
but fairness never used to me in
equality fairness means getting what you
deserve and I would argue that equality
is not what you deserve some people
deserve more and some people deserve
less based on the value they create how
do you define deserve I mean suppose
you're born with special educational
needs and it's very difficult for you to
hold down a normal job do you just
deserve to be poor because you know
something was a little bit wrong with
your brain when you were born in a sense
so let's flip there on what makes it
because you were born that way what
gives you a claim against what I produce
what gives you a claim about my effort
and my values that is I might help you
because I care for you and I care about
human beings but what gives you a claim
against me and in the end the right to
use violence against me in order to
father I never suggested what taxes what
is redistribution of wealth is
taxes violence against some for them get
your tickets for the world's largest
music and philosophy festival how the
light gets in aaaggghhh